♪ ♪
>> Sean: JOINING US NOW WITH
MORE REACTION TO THE BOMBSHELL
FLYNN DOCUMENTARY RELEASE,
LINDSEY GRAHAM.
SENATOR, I DON’T KNOW WHAT ELSE
TO SAY.
I MEAN, IS THIS THE BIGGEST SET
UP YOU’VE EVER SEEN?
I AM TOLD BY MY SOURCES THIS IS
ONLY THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
THERE ARE SO MUCH MORE COMING.
>> I THINK THERE’S MORE COMING.
IT’S PRETTY APPARENT TO ME THAT
GENERAL FLYNN WAS A VICTIM OF AN
OUT-OF-CONTROL DEPARTMENT AND
JUSTICE.
HE BASICALLY GOT RAILROADED.
AS WILDLY KNOWN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION DIDN’T HAVE MUCH
USE FOR GENERAL FLYNN.
GENERAL BARR NEEDS TO BE
COMPLEMENTED, HE IS DOING THE
RIGHT THING.
HE HAS THREE GOALS THAT I SHARE.
RESTORE TRUST, HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE WHO HAVE ENGAGED IN
MISCONDUCT, AND RIGHT A WRONG
SLUG GENERAL FLYNN AND I BELIEVE
EVENTUALLY PAT PUT UP A LIST
>> Sean: WHAT IS OUR GOAL?
TRUTH, ADMISSION, OR GET HIM TO
ALLY?
LIVE?
SENATOR, MAYBE I AM OLD SCHOOL,
OLD-FASHIONED, I DON’T KNOW.
IF SOMEBODY SERVES THEIR
COUNTRY, AND A LOT OF THAT TIME
AND WAR ZONES FOR 33 YEARS,
PROTECTING OUR LIBERTY AND OUR
CONSTITUTION, AND OUR WAY OF
LIFE, YOU WOULD THINK YOU WOULD
BEND OVER BACKWARDS.
NOT SET HIM UP, NOT SAY YOU
DON’T NEED AN ATTORNEY WHEN HE
DEFINITELY NEEDED ONE.
NOT BRAD, I SENT MY AGENT SAID
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE IN.
SOMETHING I NEVER GOT AWAY WITH
AND PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATIONS.
THAT IS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
ROOF.
THEY DIDN’T THINK HE LIED, THEY
MADE HIM PLEA AFTER HE WENT
BANKRUPT.
HE SOLD HIS HOUSE AND SAID WE
ARE PUTTING YOUR SON AND JOE IF
YOU DON’T SIGN
>> GENERAL FLYNN DESERVES BETTER
FROM THAT.
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE INVOLVED IN
THIS, I HOPE HE IS BEGINNING TO
RIGHT WRONGS.
EVERYBODY WAS ASSIGNED TO THE
FISA WARRANT AGAINST CARTER PAGE
CARTER PAGE, IT WILL BE UP TO
THEM.
THE GOAL IS TO MAKE SURE THIS
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
HE’S A WAR HERO.
>> Sean: SO MANY PEOPLE, WE
BENT ON PEELING THE LAYERS OF
THIS ON THE END.
PEOPLE ASK ME, WHEN ARE WE EVER
GOING TO GET JUSTICE?
WE ARE VERY CLOSE TO THAT NOW.
A LINE OF MOVING PARTS HERE AND
I THINK IT’S VERY REVEALING.
I’M PAYING ATTENTION.
SOME OF THE MOVEMENTS OF THE
PROSECUTOR DURHAM IN TERMS OF
HIRING MORE STAFF.
WHAT DO YOU SEE FROM THE
STATEMENTS AND ACTIONS?
>> THESE NOTES REEK OF CRIMINAL
MISCONDUCT.
I TRUST ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR TO
BE FAIR TO EVERYBODY INVOLVED
WITH THOSE BEING INVESTIGATED,
BUT HIS GOAL, I KNOW HIM VERY
WELL, IS TO RIGHT THE SHIP.
TO RESTORE TRUST.
TO HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE.
ONE OF THE WORST THINGS THAT CAN
HAPPEN IN ANY DEMOCRACY IS FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN CHARGE OF THE
LAW TO TAKE IT INTO THEIR OWN
HANDS FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES.
I THINK THAT IS WHAT HAS
HAPPENED HERE.
TIME WILL TELL.
I PROMISE YOU THAT WE WILL FIND
OUT HOW THE FBI OPERATED WHEN
THEY WERE TOLD BY THE RUSSIAN
SUB SOURCE IN JANUARY 2017, THE
DOSSIER IS A BUNCH OF GARBAGE.
I FIND IT IMPOSSIBLE TO BELIEVE
THAT DID NOT WORK ITS WAY UP
COMEY AND McCABE.
THE PERSON WHO PREPARED THE
DOSSIER FOR CHRISTOPHER STEELE
TOLD THE FBI IT’S A BUNCH OF
BARTOK AND HEARSAY.
THEY HAVE OBTAINED TWO WARRANTS
AFTER THAT.
HOW COULD THAT POSSIBLY HAPPEN?
>> Sean: PREMEDITATED FRAUD
AGAINST A FISA COURT.
IF I LIE TO A JUDGE I DON’T
THINK YOU COULD GET ME OUT OF
JAIL, AND YOU’RE PRETTY GOOD